we just saw this with jin saki the
spokesperson for the president of the
united states
i mean think about what she said she
said big tech
are now where so many people get their
news i.e they're the press
and so she said we are working with the
press to
stop certain information from getting to
we the people the american people
that that is a direct violation of their
first amendment freedom of the press
uh liberties we have that's scary and
they got some list of 12 people who they
said are putting out misinformation so
there's that sort of fundamental
question i think that's what's what the
concern is is
that marriage of big government and big
tech
i think only means conservatives get it
worse
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
congressman for ohio's
fourth district he serves as the ranking
member of the house judiciary committee
and is a co-founder of the house freedom
caucus
congressman jim jordan welcome to the
reuben report it is good to be with you
dave and uh
thank you for what you do thank you for
fighting for freedom and and first
amendment liberties for our for everyone
we i mean the country appreciates that
so uh good to be with you
oh well i appreciate the kind words i uh
can bounce that right back at you you
were one of the leaders especially i
think on the big tech stuff fighting for
free speech and free expression and
keeping the government and big tech
out of every little facet of our lives
so actually let's let's start right
there sure big
tech well i'll give you the broad
question first and then we'll get into
the specifics
big tech what do we do do you want to
regulate do you want to break them up
do you believe competition is enough is
it all of those is it none of those
no it's it's all of those and probably
some more i mean i i do think you got to
get rid of the liability protection the
so-called section 230 you got
that that's at start uh then i think you
have to give and we have we have a
series of
of they'll be in bill form soon but but
ideas we're talking about
get rid of 230 private right of action
like big tech
makes a moderate content moderation
decision about you they got to tell you
why
there needs to be some training why they
do that and frankly if they do it and
like desantis did in florida if you're a
candidate for office and they do those
kind of things
there should be a right of action you
have to hold them accountable so that's
something we're looking at
and then frankly i think you know
justice thomas has i think more than
hinted
that he wants to address this issue um
and
talking about dick big tech and the
power they have so what we're also
looking at doing is speeding up
the antitrust uh actions in our court
system so it gets to the supreme court
and we can get an answer after all the
trump administration
both the ftc brought uh any trust action
against facebook and the justice
department
has brought in any trust action against
google and we'll see how that all shakes
out with the biden
doj but i think that's where it has to
focus versus what
the democrats are talking about doing
which is just giving more power to
the ftc which i think would translate
into
um big government colluding with big
tech
to further uh stick it to conservatives
right which is pretty much what's
happening already on on the 230 point
uh my audience is all they all know
about the difference between platform
and publisher and all that
the pushback on getting rid of 230 which
i'm basically for getting rid of it so i
think
we're pretty much lined up there the
pushback though is that if you get rid
of the protections
that basically all of these platforms
twitter youtube facebook etc that they
will have to censor more
because they'll be worried about the
liability what would you say to that
legitimate concern there's also the
concern that you know they're so big
they can handle the
the the the the lawsuits that come when
they do censor people
and versus the competition that we want
to have happen
but i just think the fundamental issue
is look if they're
if they're making publishing decisions
editorial decisions
they're not supposed to have the
liability protection and that's we know
that
that's what they're doing so i i think
you just have to look at sort of the
fundamental question say okay you're
making those editorial decisions you
don't get the protection
and then and then then then go from
there but that's why i think you also
need the other things i talked about
um to actually address this again what
what concerns me most is
in an effort to deal with censorship we
have we have people embracing this idea
that oh we got to give the government
the the bureaucracy the agencies more
regulatory power
and i just think that's a mess and
frankly we just saw this we just saw
this with jin saki the spokesperson
for the president of the united states i
mean think about what she said
she said big tech are now where so many
people get their news i.e
they're the press and so she said we are
working with the press
to stop certain information from getting
to we the people the american people
that that is a direct violation of their
first amendment freedom of the press
the liberties we have that's scary and
they got some list of 12 people who they
said are putting out misinformation so
there's that sort of fundamental
question i think that's what's what the
concern is is
that marriage of big government and big
tech
i think only means conservatives get it
worse
when you hear saki say something like
that her actual
the word that to me was the where the
real bell went off was she said
we flag content for facebook
the implication is we're doing it
together right we're flagging it
for them when you hear that do you
ever go to your democratic counterparts
and go guys
look we may not agree on tax rates we
may not agree on abortion or blah blah
blah
but i thought we at least agreed on
first amendment stuff do they do they
take that meeting do they take that call
they used to i i don't know if they
would now and frankly my i have my i'm
skeptical they would now because
it has gotten so so partisan and we've
had a number of democrats some of them
on on the judiciary committee the
committee that's supposed to safeguard
the bill of rights the constitution and
americans fundamental rights and
liberties
we we've had so many of them cheer on
big tech
when they sense are conservative so it's
not the same
it used to be that you could work with i
mean i always make this
this uh tell this story dennis kucinich
former member is a friend of mine i mean
i talked to him on the phone a few
months i just texted him yesterday
because i saw him on a clip on tucker uh
dennis is an old-school liberal who says
let's let's make the best arguments to
have the debate and he was with us on
civil liberties
but that's not where today's left is
today's left is authoritarian and you're
seeing it from the spokesperson
of the president of the united states
estates in the white house
uh briefing room so it's a different
animal today
and again i think that's why you're so
concerned and i'm so concerned so many
americans are
about what's really happening to our
freedoms yeah you know dennis kucinich
is actually a perfect example when he
ran for president which was you know
probably 16 years ago something like
that yeah he was the furthest
left democrat at that point and
basically the only people who will talk
to him now
are tucker and fox news they would never
put on cnn
and he was a champion of civil we we
were on the oversight committee together
when democrats had uh power back when
demo uh when when when dennis was in
congress
he chaired this subcommittee i was the
ranking man and when it flipped i was
chairman he was ranking member
and there were issues where we could
work together typically they were civil
like we were both concerned about facial
recognition technology and how
law enforcement might use that to
violate our so we could work together
and when we didn't agree he was a true
liberal like let's have the debate let's
have get your best hold make your best
argument
let's see who wins after it's over we'll
shake hands and we'll get ready for the
next issue and have the debate
that is so different from what we see
today where it's it's so
the the vitriol and going after people
and the canceling and everything else it
is a completely different animal
i i long for the uh for the people like
kucinich like dennis kucinich who's a
good man
and and believes in so many the same
things we do when it comes to civil
liberties
different on policy where we're miles
apart on other policy issues
but um you know we need more of that
frankly in the united states congress
i think i've asked this question to
every congressman or senator that i've
had on and i'd love to know your take
too do you know
when do you have a moment or was there a
person
that you can point to when the democrats
really went off the deep end with this
stuff when it was
okay no more talking no more negotiating
you guys are all
bad guys nazis whatever nonsense they're
throwing at you do you remember when it
happened
well i mean i would probably point to
november 8 2016 when donald trump got
elected president because we know what
president trump like an individual by
the way who i think was
did an amazing job as president did more
what he said than any
any president certainly in my lifetime
uh accomplished so much
with relentless uh attacks from the left
and the
and the democrats and the media and
frankly too many republicans and still
got so much done
um but i think it probably started then
now there may be something else but the
first thing that popped to mind was
the day he wins election democrats have
been
you know going after him and continue to
do so now five years later
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling check out our
politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell